how are you doing today i'm good how are
you i'm good this is super exciting i
mean
you know we've known you for a long time
we've loved your music for a long time
but here we go this album is out
right and like we got to measure the
level of excitement that you're feeling
like from one to a million where are you
at with this i'm it's definitely up in
the millions for sure
i think i think there's some some
nervousness somewhere in there so it
might not be
at a million but it's it's definitely
close
do you how much of what people's
reactions
are to your music or what will be to
this album do you take into account like
do you pay attention to the fans
obviously saying
they love it how much of it will affect
you um
probably a lot of it um you know i
i really value my fans i love them all
very much
and you know i i definitely wanted to
resonate with them as much as possible
um you know criticism is always a little
scary
but you know i i wouldn't i wouldn't put
out very vulnerable music if i wasn't um
if i wasn't uh ready for something like
that i guess
yeah well and it is very vulnerable
music we you know we've talked before
about where you write from
and the experiences that you're drawing
on how do you
um i don't know if the world has shield
yourself
but how do you prepare for when you know
you're gonna read things that
someone maybe misinterpreted something
that you wrote or
something doesn't someone doesn't like a
thing that you love that you made
um i mean it it can get a little scary
because if someone doesn't like
something uh you know they're kind of
saying they don't like a certain part of
you
which is a little nerve-wracking um but
i especially on like release days i try
to
do things that i love to sort of
distract myself a little bit
so i'll go eat something that i really
love or go somewhere that i really love
just to to find some sort of balance
so the songs here where are they from
are they all
recently in the making are some of them
a long time in the making
no i wrote most of them last year
i think it started at the end of spring
and then
it ended in january so these are all
very relevant to my life
now where we're at right now in your
life
and where are you at in your life right
now where my at
i am in love um currently
i'm very happy i feel
um i don't know just a lot of a lot of
contentness right now i think
it's lovely to see um i mean i love
seeing you happy i love seeing that the
happiness
resonate in your social in the
interviews that you do
like you know last time we talked we
were talking with jp too and the two you
were just like
i was like okay do i need to be here
right now do i need to be here
that sounds sounds correct
you know when it comes to love love is
obviously a journey
and you'll learn so much about yourself
like every day
what have you learned about yourself and
about love
over the course of writing this project
well i think with my last eps
you know i i have you know i have
anxiety and i have depression and
you know all these things that sort of
plague me and i think i've always
thought that i
am not good enough for love or don't
deserve love or if i do i deserve a
certain type of love
and that love is you know just sort of
chaotic and dramatic and toxic and
i think it it took me falling in love
with someone that was
loving and supportive and met me halfway
and waited for me when i wasn't there
yet
to realize that it's not and that it
doesn't have to be and that you can
deserve love that is
easy and communicative and um
you know you you can it can be beautiful
and it can be passionate in a
non-chaotic way
that's something that you know is a
message that you really feel a lot of
people need to hear right
definitely absolutely i think it's
important to know that you
you do deserve healthy love in spite of
what you may think of yourself
yeah i love that um you know when people
talk about the love languages
right like that's gifts or
different different types of affection i
get a sense that with the two of you
part of that is
you know you've talked about the support
you show each other but also like
that through the creative process like
what
kind of role did jp play when you are
say bouncing ideas off of him
or maybe you know unsure about
even sharing an idea i mean i don't know
if that's what if you know if
that's similar that happened but like
what kind of role do you guys play out
together when you're creating your music
um i mean for the most part
it it's really just you know i'm at the
helm of of my music but if
if i you know one day i'm feeling like
hey i really want to write a song like
this
i mean why would i not write a song with
the best songwriter that's literally
laying in bed right beside me
um that happened with this song that's
on my album called little did i know
i was sitting in bed and i was like you
know i really want to write a song like
this
and he was like let's do it and we wrote
it in five different places and it
turned out to be one of my favorite
love songs i've ever written in my life
um and for all your ex's i mean that's
that started that started as a
conversation
and then as a very sarcastic
situation that turned into a song that i
love
um you know i'm grateful that we still
can write with each other
and he doesn't take anything that i say
personally in the studio
because i can be a bit alpha and intense
i think
so uh i'm very i'm very grateful that he
lets me get all my neuroses out yes
leave it up to you to write a song about
um like murdering someone's actions but
make it a problem and have it be stuck
in your head all day thank you i
think that's a compliment thank you very
much well i'm on the video too like the
video is so
camp like it's right it goes right in
there yeah it must have been a lot of
fun to
to make but who when they saw it like
who of your close friends and family
when they saw it were like
yo i love this like this is crazy for
you
actually it's funny my my dad was the
first person
to text me and he
my dad moved to california to be an
actor
and it didn't really go the way that he
hoped and he always said that he thought
he was supposed to move to california
for him but he realized that he was
supposed to move to california for me
so this was the first time that i had
ever essentially acted in a music video
and even though i was playing this
stepford wife
psychotic human being my dad was like my
baby's acting
[Laughter]
funny he was so proud but we definitely
did
have a lot of fun that day
oh it looks like a blast you know when
we talked to baby rex about like the
blood that she used in her video she
said it was like
colored water and it's stained like what
was it like for you did it
stay in your stuff did it smell what was
it it was awful
it was the first time i ever i ever had
to do anything with fake blood
and it wasn't um it definitely wasn't
water
it was it was some like sugary sticky
something and it was just my hair was
stuck to my body if i had my arms up
like this for too long like if say i was
really cold and i put my arms down my
arm would like
was sticking to myself it was so gross
we had to like take wipes
and get it off my body and it it took me
a good
two and a half hours in the bathtub to
just like get it off my skin
amazing yeah amazing um
you know with your we've talked to
people about your songwriting before
like keith urban said oh she writes
songs so fast
it just kind of comes out it just
happens and
obviously the more that you do something
you know the better you get at it and
you've been doing this for a long time
how do you do you feel like your
songwriting process is easier do you
feel like it's i know faster means
better
like what is it like for you now i mean
i can't really tell you i i mean i've
written songs in under an hour that have
been some of my bigger songs i've
written songs in six hours you know it's
i don't think the i don't think the
amount of time
um dictates whether a song is going to
be really good or not um
i i tend to just go with my subconscious
and go with my sort of thoughts and
feelings and memories um
and you know i don't do you know i don't
know music theory
i don't do the math when it comes to you
know music
i don't do any of that stuff i just i
just rely on feeling
and and hope that it turns into
something beautiful
yeah um this
the stories are so personal here um and
of course they resonate universally um
and it's you
it's like it's it's your story it's your
voice but with you know we just
mentioned keith
keith sean selina you've got friends
that are um
musicians did you ever think about
bringing anyone else onto the project
like
as a feature or to work with you on it
um
no i did that in the past and it was
really wonderful and i'm
i'm so grateful to have extremely
talented friends
um but i i think i just wanted my first
album to be very much
my point of view my perspective and and
just for my fans to see me
what does it feel like to say that
you've got your first album
like your first full album now
it feels wild i mean i if you would have
told me five years ago that this was
going to happen i would have been like
no way absolutely
um you know it took a lot of
insecurities a lot of anxiety
a lot of you know conquering of fears to
get to this point
um and yeah it's definitely been a long
process and i
i definitely wasn't ready for a very
long time and here i am and here it is
and
let's go wonderful thing what are you
doing these days
to help yourself through those
harder feelings of insecurity or
whatever it is that you happen to be
going through
um you know i'm really big on self-care
days
i think they're really important
especially for me
i can tend to be more introverted than
than a lot of people in my life and with
that comes you know
needing to sort of protect my energy
sometimes i get really overwhelmed and
over stimulated really easy so
doing things even if it's just for like
an hour
that make me feel better um you know
taking a drive listening to music
putting my feet in some sort of body of
water
or in some grass or eating something
that i really love
you know those little things help me
sort of get back to center
you